je m'aperçois que j'ai commis une erreur
c'est compliqué tout pas de la police
municipale maintenant j'ai quand même le
faire voilà merci beaucoup pour cet
exposé très complet inquiétant mais
comparé le terrorisme c'est toujours
quelque chose qui évidemment est
inquiétant ça ne sert à rien de se
fermer les yeux puisque nous avons
affaire à des gens qui nous ont déclaré
la guerre et il va bien falloir se
défendre un mot avant de passer aux
questions réponses la police municipale
c'est quelque chose je vous dédie qui
nous différencie beaucoup de david
hidalgo qui n'en veut pas nous le
souhaitons
cette police municipale étaient dans le
programme de nathalie kosciusko morizet
malheureusement nous n'avons pas été
élus et donc nous la mettrons pas en
oeuvre pendant cette mandature
je remercie et sénateurs présents ici
notamment pierre charon et sato dominati
puisque il avait porté une proposition
de loi permettant la création d'une
police municipale à paris puisque
aujourd'hui la loi l'interdît mais
refuser la police municipale à paris
c'est un c'est un débat de fond mais
c'est un débat qui est perdue parce que
tout va dans le sens d'un maire de paris
de plus en plus important c'est parce
qu'il est l'élu et vous ne pouvez pas
avoir un élu
s'il n'a pas des pouvoirs de police
cette police municipale d'ailleurs elle
coûterait pas grand chose parce qu'elle
existe déjà il ya déjà trois mille
hommes et femmes qui sont payés par la
mairie de paris avec vos impôts 2000 qui
s'occupe exclusivement de la répression
du stationnement payant qui sont
pourtant tous agents de police
judiciaire adjoints et qu'ils pourraient
former l'ossature de cette police
municipale et nous avons aussi à la
ville de paris mines inspecteurs de
sécurité de la ville de paris qui sont
posés les tâches diverses
donc on voit bien que à à francs
constants à 1 po constants on a une
force de 3000 hommes et femmes
parisiennes qui ont la capacité
juridique et qui pourrait être la
ceinture de police municipale pourquoi
avoir besoin d'une police municipale
pour deux raisons la première il faut
permettre à la police nationale de se
dégager d'un certain nombre de missions
pour que la police comme la gendarmerie
mais elle a peu à paris c'est
essentiellement exclusivement la police
nationale qui intervient
puis se recentrer sur son coeur de
métier qui est de lutter contre le
banditisme d'arrêter des voyous de
lutter contre le terrorisme
donc cette création des polices
municipales bien loin d'être en
concurrence est la police nationale sera
pour la police nationale
une aide ça permettra aux forces de
sécurité nationales de se recentrer sur
leur coeur de métier
la seconde c'est que ça permet de donner
à vous aux citoyens au parisien quelque
chose d'immédiat salle est une ville est
organisée autour de la sécurité
le lieutenant général de police la
reynie yates à quelques centaines
d'années avaient eu comme idée
d'illuminer les rues de paris la nuit
c'est à dire de mettre un petit peu
partout des stocks de gaz mais c'étaient
des bougies pour qu'on y voit la nuit et
à partir du moment où les rues ont été
éclairés et bien les agressions limin
une manière considérable donc la
sécurité ça commence par l'éclairage la
nuit
ça commence par la propreté ça commence
par le respect des uns et des autres et
tout s'est tu
c'est ce qu'on appelle les incivilités
dont tout ce qui est un frappe et nal
qui ne constitue pas aujourd'hui un
crime ou un délit mais quitte
insupportable par un citoyen le bruit
les déjections canines
les tags etc etc et bien la police
municipale permettra sous l'autorité du
maire de paris de répondre et de
résoudre ces questions
voilà rapidement brossé le tableau soit
police municipale